one of the most important tips I can
give about a sow is think like a search
engine you want to give signals to the
search engine if it's play if it's
iTunes if it's whatever such an engine
there is that your app is relevant and
useful so for example anchor text encode
text is huge in SEO if we will think
about most of the let's say articles
that we know in the Internet Google Play
iTunes download the anchor text has
nothing to do with the actual app we're
losing SEO juice we're losing SEO juice
make sure that the anchor text has
something to do with your app the best
closing gap or again the 12 downloading
or a game about fish whatever make sure
that the anchor text makes sense also
make sure to be relevant make sure that
people are not uninstalling your your
app immediately on that note another
great technique to get users is paid
campaigns there's many ways to do it
there's many affiliate networks and
there's a lot of display campaigns but
because one of the best signals that the
App Store's are getting is a lot of
downloads a lot of installs sometimes
you want to invest in getting more paid
downloads because that will eventually
get you more organic downloads another
thing is the comments the people that
are giving bad reviews are giving them
mostly for reason and mostly because
they didn't get what they were expecting
to get so if you're using a name that
makes sense if the images that you're
using are actually elaborate and explain
what this product is all about and it's
not some kind of illustration that has
nothing to do with your website if the
description is accurate and use exact in
describe exactly what you're going to
get the meta tags make sense everything
makes sense and correlate with your
product that's the best approach so ASO
tricks the best thing that you can do is
optimize your app page you can a be test
everything from the icon that
representing your app to the description
to the meta tags to the images to the
video that you're using you can optimize
everything another thing is if you have
something in the app store if you have
an option to do something targeted use
it if there's special special display
for tablets do it if you can translate
localization is so important if you can
use Portuguese for brazillian translate
your app because that will be much
better translate the images be
professional invest time on creating
though in creating this representation
because that's the only asset that you
can control you can control how people
will react to your app but you can
control about what they understand you
can test it you can test it you can
iterate about you can iterate on it and
that's the best the best advice I can
get